vivre c'est une application très simple
d'utilisation qui permet aux salariés de
trouver le meilleur lieu pour son
logement
l'objectif est de rapprocher
réduire les temps de transport et de
rapprocher l'habitat emploi c'est un
service qui est mis à la disposition des
entreprises qui est gratuit pour les
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés qui
une participation financière pour les
autres
pour pouvoir définir ces critères on
commence par définir la composition du
foyer
donc par exemple deux adultes admettons
que nous avons deux enfants
ensuite l'application permet en fonction
des ja de la composition de la famille
de faire une première sélection de
critères par exemple on peut être très
proche de certains services de santé
avoir des écoles à proximité puisque on
a mis des enfants en bas âge accéder
facilement à des commerces
après c'est des questions par rapport au
lieu de travail
le mode de transport et ensuite quel
logement est recherché ensuite le
logiciel agréger toutes les bases de
données et va vous faire des
propositions sur les lieux qui sont le
plus adapté en fonction des critères que
vous avez identifié
si vous cliquez sur une des communes qui
a été proposée vous pouvez explorer le
lieu avoir accès à tous les services sur
la commune en particulier sur tout
l'environnement et puis vous avez accès
à toutes les offres
des agences immobilières soin
particulier à particulier soit le bon
coin donc toutes les offres qui
correspondent aux critères demandés